breakthroughs in molecular biology
advances of precision medicine
biotechnology and agriculture
have translated into advanced
technologies
that simplify the generation of accurate
and
in-depth data however a lack of
analytical power and appropriate skills
create a huge gap between data and the
information
that is needed in these fields in most
cases that means that our ability to
analyze data and extract meaningful
information
is lagging behind the pace of new data
that is being generated
oftentimes clinicians biologists and
students from life science backgrounds
report about their challenge with data
analysis and interpretation
that is holding them back limiting their
ability to rely on advanced techniques
like genomic sequencing
so what can our education system do
about this gap how do schools
colleges and universities prepare
students for the future of biotechnology
and life sciences in general
where biology is acquiring the
characteristics of the data science
how can we merge life and data sciences
together
in a practical way that is both
inclusive
and effective how do we prepare students
for successful research and industry
careers
giving them skills and experiences that
help them navigate their future
since these topics are so pressing
we are organizing a research symposium
that is dedicated to the future of
bioinformatics education
where we will cover critical challenges
and identify
new solutions for improved educational
strategies focused on biology
as a data science in the symposium we
will bring together experts
that will be addressing the pressing
challenges with data science education
for all life science students
and explore how to best equip life
science students and data science skills
for the 21st century our speakers will
bring their perspectives as researchers
that are working on cutting-edge topics
in bioinformatics
directors of successful academic degree
programs
that are seeing their students continue
a successful careers in education
academic research and industry together
they will offer a comprehensive view of
opportunities for students
that want to make the most of their
studies and focus on acquiring skills
that matter
helping them become successful and
making a true difference
in the symposium we will discuss such
topics as how to stand out from the
crowd when you apply
for academic programs or careers in
bioinformatics
what can universities do to equip their
students with relevant skills and
experiences
and what is the future of this field and
where will you find the cutting edge
challenges
that you can also contribute to
importantly students will be able to
showcase their research projects that
are being developed in collaboration
between faculty and students
across important domains and life
sciences with translational
outcomes during this time you will also
be able to speak with our network of
mentors
and judges that will review submitted
project presentations and posters
and select the best ones with the
potential
and quality that is worthy of
recognition
and prizes we will also hear about some
exciting updates being worked on
for the t by info platform that combines
multiple methods of omics data analysis
across a wide range of applications
these include a range of bioinformatics
sections for single cell data analysis
and integration
analysis and modeling of cancer cell and
viral replication and evolution
as well as exciting new applications of
quantum computing
for a variety of challenges in life
sciences
our team will also share exciting new
updates about the omixlogic training
modules that are being designed
for biology as a data science our team
will introduce regional collaborations
in the united states
india and africa highlighting important
modules that can be applied
to oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture
we will introduce some new modules and
project examples for precision medicine
as a pre-clinical and clinical training
option
we will discuss how this pandemic gave
public awareness about the infectious
diseases
and what kinds of hands-on exercises
students can access
to learn about viral bacterial and
parasite-caused infections
using public domain data we will discuss
agriculture
the rise of technology driven precision
agrotechnology
with a focus on sustainable food supply
climate resistant strain breeding
and methods of bioinformatics analysis
that are in high demand
in this industry finally we will
introduce our new and planned
specializations like the field of
astrobiology
that is captivating the minds of
students who are seeing the commercial
space industry developing before their
eyes
this will be in addition to our existing
modules for which you will gain access
to the omixlogic portal
where you can try and explore these
modules exercises and pipeline building
coding and various methods of analysis
using project source from peer-reviewed
publications
importantly students are looking for
academic programs where they can
continue their studies
during the symposium our speakers will
share information about the programs
that they are associated with
and what their focus and differences are
as you consider to continue your
education
we will also bring together companies
that will share
what skills they are looking for and how
your experience
might make your resume stand out we also
will introduce
internship and fellowship programs for
those of you interested
to get your foot into the industry or
explore
different types of research
opportunities importantly we hope that
this symposium
will be the place where all levels of
bioinformatics
from data generation to data analysis
and integration
to decision making are going to be
addressed and
make bioinformatics training biology as
a data science
accessible to a larger number of
students
universities and companies
so if you would like to participate we
invite you to start your registration
you can opt for just an observer
or a participant to submit your poster
for
cash prizes and recognition from
a respected panel of judges and experts
that will take a look and evaluate every
poster that is being submitted